[Music]
we wanted to give our version of
spider-man we wanted to I say we want
people to say that feels like a
spider-man game from insomniac we wanted
to have the DNA the feel of what people
expect from spider-man but same time I
feel like oh that feels like in some
icky I feel like the traversal of Sunset
is taken with spider-man the the gadgets
from resistance and ratchet now or in
spider-man with a suit power to the
gadgets and then just overall humor that
spider-man is known for as well as we
are on the ration Clank sighs when
spider counts on the job come hell or
high water
good job kids I would say my favorite
detail is that all the things we put in
this apartment like that that initial
camera pan that you see down from the
window to the very beginning when he
grabbed his phone and then all the
things in between to me that just like
there's like Easter eggs upon Easter egg
so it's all those little elements and it
also feel like it captures who Peter is
really quickly like you know his history
you know kind of a sloppy is same time
but also like this is Peter Parker he's
struggling to pay his bills he's has
long history with all these villains and
the end of the day he's just trying to
catch up on sleep so he can go fight
another bad guy Oh God who would win
spider-man a Kratos sorry Cory it's
gonna be spider-man all the way you can
put that you can put that into it he'll
he'll look at it you're you okay you mix
out of that building we're gonna lose
him I'm gonna go
do your thing yes anytime you making a
spider-man game you say well we're gonna
sometime not play a spider-man it's a
risk right because he's such a popular
character I mean that's why people love
him they want to experience him but we
thought that to tell a full like a
360-degree super superhero story you had
to show what is it like when you're not
a superhero in that world and we thought
MJ would be a great example of that at
the same time for her arc to really have
a full arc and experience it the right
way at certain points in the story it
would really benefit a few plate as her
so there's definitely a risk and then I
was just from a technical standpoint
creating another playable character is
always a thing we got to juggle and the
team did a great job I'm super proud of
it
biggest worry about MJ is just are we
being respectful of the character and
are we are we making it something that
people will enjoy a play and you know
even though it might not be as high
intense as you know fighting a
spider-man there are missions with very
high stakes that you will be in control
of MJ and I love that you will you will
physically actually get to play out her
story
[Music]
[Music]
you